plotting an escape in a car nearly
totaled by shelling what sure this
mother did everything she could think of
to make her vehicle appear
non-threatening to the occupying
russians white strips of fabric on the
door handles symbols of peace and a sign
that says children written in russian
if i stayed longer i may have lost my
car how could i live then so we ran away
valentina shows me a video on her phone
of what used to be her apartment in
mariupol she and her two-year-old son
weren't there when it was destroyed
they've spent the past two months
running basement to basement apartment
to apartment their last hiding place
became home to about 300 people
he's too young and i hope he will not
remember those terrible events daniel
may not but yuri certainly does yeah
he says i already lived under occupation
once it was in 1941 i no longer want to
live under the occupiers again at 94 his
hearing is poor and so is his health his
daughter svetlana helps us communicate
with him she says he understands what
they're going through
they won't run away from a good man once
a hotel this building is housing 130
refugees yuri is the oldest
since russia invaded 2 000 others have
sought shelter here it's quiet and kept
dimly lit for safety
safety and small comforts don't erase
heartbreak the pain of leaving home is
immense for people here on their first
day and months later ilana andriy and
their teenage daughter and his parents
all escaped together his furniture shop
in mariopol like almost everything else
destroyed ukraine we had two floors in
the building and all of these lawns
the loans still remain people here say
they won't go home unless they know
they'll be living under a ukrainian flag
and in the southeast
that's far from certain
krystal gavinson global news zaparizia
ukraine